to
day
three of our workshop
thank you and we're thrilled to have
nica hogtelab here from uc berkeley
who works in algorithms and machine
learning
and today she's going to be talking
about learning with adaptive smooth
adversaries so take it away
thank you for the invitation and thank
you all for being here
yeah the title of the talk as you can
see is learning with adaptive smooth
adversaries and we're going to really be
exploring a perspective of smooth
analysis on machine learning
this is a joint work with tim rof gordon
who i'm sure you all know and matt met
and abhishek shetty who is my phd
student
abhishek is actually present in the room
so
if you need help recognizing him this is
his mask face
um yeah so he's around a lot in simon's
and
he you can definitely talk with him and
you're gonna get to know about all of
his other amazing works as well
so um
we're going to be talking about
ml algorithmic and statistical
guarantees in this talk
and they're usually considered in two
different worlds one that is stochastic
or sometimes we call them offline and
another which is adversarial robust or
online world
so in the stochastic world the
assumption is that data that you're
working with is stochastically generated
from some fixed distribution that's
unknown
the learner wants to learn a function
using this data
and the learner is successful if it has
a good performance over this underlying
distribution
and this model is not at all concerned
about what happens if the world were to
change tomorrow if the distribution
shifts if i'm still going to do well or
not
there's the adversarial robust or online
setting where the assumption is that the
data is generated by an all-powerful
adversary this is an adaptive adversary
who knows the world and knows the
history and knows the algorithm
and
our algorithm is successful if it can
get good performance over
any adversarially generated sequence
no matter what
and this is specifically made to have
robustness as part of the guarantees
because you're robust to any
misspecification any changes in the data
any attacks by just definition
so it's not surprising that these two
types of guarantees are actually quite
different from each other
a lot of cases we can get the type of
guarantees in the stochastic world that
we want quite easily with very little
data or very little computation
but once you start thinking about the
adversarial world you actually have
impossibility results that say that you
cannot learn at all no matter how much
data or how much time you have
and this is the unfortunate thing
because we really do care about
robustness and in particular i think
more and more these days we care about
robustness more because we are seeing
increased interactions between learning
algorithms and people and these
types of interactions are unpredictable
they can switch based on time and shift
the distribution
and robustness is really important to
actually make sure that these algorithms
are going to continue performing well in
presence of people
and here kind of like the impossibility
results for not being able to deal with
a worst case all-powerful adversary
does not actually discourage us or
invalidate like the actual goal of
wanting to be robust rather what it
tells us is that we need to think about
new models that can actually guide the
design of algorithms that can be robust
if not to worst-case all-powerful
adversaries to at least everyday type of
adversaries that you're going to see
and our goal and hope is that by finding
the right models and that provide the
right guidance to us
we can essentially get the same
performance guarantees that we could get
in the stochastic world and now get it
for all sort of day-to-day type of
realistic adversaries we're going to
face
this is the overall view of what you're
going to do today
it's of course not new this is something
that we've been doing in just algorithm
design as well it's not just about
learning theory
and algorithm design the two fields of
average case analysis on worst-case
analysis exactly look at for average
case like how can we deal with instances
that were stochastically generated from
a fixed distribution and in the worst
case setting uh we want to analyze what
happens to algorithms if instances were
generated by an adversary
and
also in the algorithms world we've seen
that one
average case analysis could be much much
easier than worst case analysis
so looking at the algorithmic world the
solution to sort of interpolates between
average case analysis and worst case
analysis the main
framework that we use as smooth analysis
many of you are familiar with this this
is a smooth analysis framework of
spielman intend
which
essentially the idea there is that you
have an adversary that chooses an
instance
but then the nature comes in and
perturbs this instance a little bit
perhaps by adding a gaussian noise to it
and the goal of analysis here is that
for any adversarially generated instance
we can perform well in expectation or
with high probability over this noise
there's a slightly more modern
perspective on
thinking about how we would frame smooth
analysis
and in this setting rather than thinking
that an adversary first comes and then
the nature comes in we just think that
the adversary is selecting a
distribution where the instances are
going to be generated from this
distribution
and this distribution should not be too
concentrated on any any one instance so
it's dispersed and anti-concentrated
and the goal there is that for any
anti-concentrated sufficiently
anti-concentrated distribution
we want our algorithms to perform well
again either in expectation or with high
probability
this type of smooth analysis
framework is
most useful first of all when you have a
big gap between the average case and
worst case analysis because it's really
trying to go in between them
and especially useful when we see really
good performance in average case but the
reason worst case analysis is not doing
very well is that
there were these really brutal
constructions that once you add a little
bit of noise they start breaking down
ideally what we really want is that we
are looking at smooth analysis we can
get average case analysis type
guarantees for a world that is
essentially worst case plus of noise
smooth analysis of course has a glorious
past and present and hopefully future
it was originally introduced then
for
the setting of thinking about how
simplex does
um particularly simply as we know
simplex does poorly on worst-case
generated
instances it can have an exponential
runtime but when you add a little bit of
perturbations it actually finds a good
solution within a quite a small
polynomial time
it has also been used for other
algorithmic
problems like clustering or tsp
but what i'm hoping to do today is to
convince you that
machine learning is also and theory of
machine learning is also what should be
one of the main applications of smooth
analysis and i think it should
perform a fundamental
role in
the type of problems we study
and here
not only we care about computation but
in fact we care even more so about
information
because
even definition of what is learnable
depends on how much information and how
much like statistical information we
need
and this is also something that the
model of the adversary or the stochastic
world are going to impact
okay so i've been talking about um
worst case
learning stochastic learning
let me start by actually giving you some
frameworks that we can we can continue
using throughout the talk
for today's talk when i talk about you
know
this kind of adversarial learning i
really mean online adversarial full
information
so what does that look like an example
of this is that
we have an unknown threshold a
any instance that any instance x that we
get above a is going to be labeled
positive any instance below it is going
to be labeled negative
and we want an algorithm that can
predict this the label of the next
incoming
instance
and these instances are chosen
adaptively and adversarially
so
in this case let's look at a bad example
and essentially prove why it's
impossible to learn effectively in the
online setting
think about an adversary that asks you
to label one half
you can say plus or minus it really
doesn't matter
but whatever you say let's say that
algorithm predicted that the label of
this thing was minus
the adversary can pretend that the
algorithm made a mistake and say that
actually no the label was plus one
and it can then continue asking a
question without really shrinking the
space of all available thresholds that
would be
still in the running
so then it asks for one fourth again it
really doesn't matter what the algorithm
says
the adversary can pretend that the
algorithm was wrong
and continued this way
this construction the important thing
about this construction is that when i
quit in fact i don't need to quit i can
take this to infinity
there's still one threshold a that was
consistent with all the things the
adversary said
so the
if i look back at my sequence there is a
perfect threshold that explains
everything
uh and it can explain it for any route
that the algorithm and adversary took
but what happened was that the algorithm
had no idea whatever it did it
essentially ended up being a mistake
so in this case the algorithm over t
times steps is making a number of
mistakes that's exactly t so we say that
the algorithm is not learning because
it's you know
it just
makes a mistake at every round
so this is an impossibility of one
example of impossibility in learning in
an online setting
what could have the offline world look
like the offline world the sequence is
not adversarial anymore it just comes
from
one distribution
i still have the same rule about there
is a threshold that is consistent with
the pluses and minuses it's just that
the instances the x's are generated at
random yeah
what the distribution is no the number
does not know if the distribution so
this distribution is unknown and still
wants to learn this a
so why can you actually learn in this
setting there is a simple setting like
simple way to think about it
let's say that this is a distribution i
don't really know the distribution but
there exists one and this would have
been my perfect a so
let's take the following naive algorithm
which wastes its first square root of t
time by just doing arbitrary stuff it
really doesn't care it just wants to do
something to get an observation
and within this like one of our epsilon
rounds
it's uh going to predict
uh
this should have been reversed
it's going to predict however at once
and it's going to make mistakes that are
like at every round so square root of t
mistakes
then what it's going to do is that it's
going to look back at these square root
of t rounds and it's going to take just
one threshold that looked consistent
with the history that's the a bar this
is erm okay
and what that happens is that
um it's gonna just put some a bar that's
consistent and from then on up to the
rest of the time it's going to use a bar
to predict
now why is this a good algorithm the
claim is that
first of all the number of mistakes you
made here wasn't a lot it's sublinear in
t so
compared to making t mistakes over t
times steps it's not a big deal at all
what about the mistakes you make in the
future
it shouldn't be hard to see that this a
bar is converging to a quite fast
and the reason for this is that
essentially after square root of t
rounds
if i look at any
interval of length epsilon around a
i would have seen with high probability
some sample falling in that region
and because it fell in that region my a
bar would have been inconsistent with it
so the fact that a bar is itself
consistent
is the thing that is telling me that the
number of mistakes i'll make from now
until future is going to be bounded then
small
okay so this is a very naive algorithm
and they've proof of what the difference
between the online setting and the
offline setting looks like
and it's something that
typically you might learn this in the
first graduate learning theory course
okay let me give you a formal setup
of what
generally speaking for any function
class offline and online learning are
defined as
so the offline learning setting so this
is the stochastic world you have an
unknown distribution d over x y
y's are the labels x's are the instances
and you have a function class h
at every round t you're
taking this learn the learner has to
pick a function ft
which is not necessarily like you don't
need to take it deterministically
and then the world will pick xt yt from
a distribution
and the algorithm makes a mistake if it
makes a mistake
now we want to get sub-linear and key
regret and regret is really defined as
the difference between the algorithm's
number of mistakes
versus the number of mistakes that the
best classifier would have made
so when we were talking about these
thresholds a the number of mistakes the
best classifier made in my tree was zero
the number of mistakes the algorithm
made was t
so i did not have a no regret algorithm
then
but in the offline setting the number of
mistakes the algorithm made was root t
the number of mistakes that the
hypothesis hypothesis made was zero so
it was a no regret algorithm
the reason we are interested in nor
regret is that as t goes to infinity
essentially the average regret which is
the average extra number of mistakes
you're making is going to go to zero and
it's going to be no worse than the best
predictor
okay so that's the formal setup of
offline learning what happens to online
learning
online learning we don't have a
distribution this is where the adversary
inserting itself
so at every round the adversary is
picking xdyt having known all of the
history and the algorithm at play
the middle ground smooth analysis here
is going to look like how we are going
to introduce some noise to the adversary
i'll say it in two different ways
you can think about having a function
class h the same function class we're
just like working exactly with the same
setup
and we're still working with a setup
that the predictor the learner has to
pick a predictor and their adversary is
creating an instance
but how the adversaries create an
instance is by picking a sigma smooth
distribution dt
having known the history so far in the
algorithm
what is the sigma smooth if you recall i
was talking about smooth analysis
earlier on as picking an
anti-concentrated distribution
that's what a sigma distribu a sigma
smooth distribution is a sigma smooth
distribution is one that its max density
is not much larger than the uniform
density so it's like one over sigma
times the uniform density
and
if you wanted to like think more about
sort of the more classical perspective
on smooth analysis another way to think
about this is that again the adversary
picked on xtyt
and we randomly perturbed it these are
essentially equivalent um up to some
parameters as long as you have a finite
limit measure on the domain that you're
working with which we're just going to
use that as an assumption
okay so
we talked about offline learning online
learning and smooth perspective on
online learning
what we do know about these cases are
that
if you're just like thinking about worst
case
online learning is known to be much
worse than offline learning in fact
there's a combinatorial dimension called
the little zone dimension
that defines characterizes the regret in
the online setting
vc dimension characterizes regret in the
offline setting and we know that a
little some dimension is much much
larger than vc dimension and the
threshold case vc dimension is one
the little sun dimension is infinite for
the purpose of this talk you don't
actually need to know what little sun
dimension is we don't care about it
what you
would benefit from is knowing that
little sun dimension is always less than
log of age
so if you had a finite class you could
have learned it's really the infinite
classes that are creating problems for
us
now
what we are going to show you is that
when you are thinking about smooth
adversaries the regret effectively is
going to look like offline setting
in the sense that is still characterized
by the vc dimension
but of course it's going to have some
dependence on the amount of perturbation
the more perturbation you have the
closer it's going to look like the
regret in the offline studying if you
have no perturbation it's going to
go back to the little dimension
yes sigma as sort of a
noise
parameter does this does does something
have to do with like a signal to noise
ratio in terms of this
um
you could think about signal to noise
instead of thinking about signal to
noise i think it's better to think about
the domain size to noise i think that is
a better intuition to have here of
course these are related to each other
yes
[Music]
i mean the little sum dimension is
infinity but
if i have a bound on the range
in which my threshold lies of size t
then it's logarithmic
yeah so
the
so okay so t is the number of times
that's right i mean h if uh i don't know
call it m or something
i know that my church has been about
somewhere between minus m and m
unfortunately not so even if you put it
it's kind of scale free unfortunately
and that's the issue if you have a
discretized set that i say it lies
between one two three to m all integers
then yes because you have m options and
then you can use this but if it's just
lying between zero to one it's somewhat
scale free because then i'm doing that
half
but what happens let me see
problem is too many real numbers
yeah it's exactly you
right so i mean what if like how does
the square with i mean there are like
classical results that in the mistake
found in setting that you can learn
linear threshold functions only if there
are finitely many of them they're all
there's always an asterisk
okay so if there's some bounded decision
bounded precision euro okay exactly so
this this is exactly the issue if you
have
um
if i i discretize this so that i have
two to the some number of them
then you're going to get a regret that's
going to be square root of t like let's
say i have n
uh like 2 to the n here then you're
going to get square root of t n as n
goes to infinity you don't have a
discretization this is going to go to
not being able to learn yeah it's
interesting because
we do think about these um
we teach them differently than they are
actually used and in fact this little
sun dimension whenever you have a
threshold in your class
essentially little simulation is
infinite
no um
so when we think about the sigma smooth
that's just so that we don't have to
think about noise models at all
so sigma smooth just means that you can
pick any distribution
correlated with the pass
as in your choice of distribution is
correlated with the past
but it cannot have infinitely large
density
okay so this is
what we've seen this is what we're going
to do
any questions any other questions you
have good questions
okay so
yeah
one thing i was talking about
learnability is that we talk about like
the reason we like to think about
norwegian is that we define learnability
in that sense so you're learnable the
class is learnable if you can get
sub-linear and t-regret
so this is actually changing our
perspective of what is learnable
previously we thought that you know
classifiers with large levels on
dimension were not learnable in the
adversarial setting
but this is really telling us is that
actually they are learnable in this
smoothed version of the problem
so just changing the characterization
entirely yeah
so
in one sense the smooth analysis setup
is not exactly an interpolation between
the two because
in the pure stochastic setting you don't
need uh
there's only one distribution for all
time
and it need not be sigma smooth
yeah it's it's actually this is
something that's a little that's more
interesting as a difference between um
more algorithmic way of thinking and
more ml theoretic way of thinking
which is that when we talk about average
case analysis and if here also when i
take sigma to be
one
i am essentially talking about
uniformity
whereas the offline setting actually
works for any distribution not just any
any fixed distribution yes there's a
little bit of dissonance here i
completely agree with you it happens to
be um
so when i talk about this being a
characterization i'm just hiding some
stuff that i i will be happy to reveal
offline in the talk not offline online
after this
but yeah it's a very good observation
okay
so
to see why smooth analysis helps here is
uh important to maybe take a look at the
stochastic case
and
actually before i do that let me just
say that another important aspect here i
said it but i think i should just say it
one more time is that
this sigma smooth distribution you were
asking about the noise model it's really
important that
um
you have the knowledge of the history of
the past right so it's it's not that
i just at the beginning i picked the
sequence of like
anti-concentrated distributions really
that diversity is still quite
adversarial and adaptive it can adapt to
the past
and this is the thing we are trying to
really deal with because if the
adversary wasn't very adaptive
we would be back in the typical way of
looking at smooth analysis the
adaptivity here is actually a
significant challenge
okay so why did the stochastic setting
work
at a high level one explanation for this
is that even when you have an infinite
hypothesis class
you can take a finite
net of this a finite cover for it
and then just pretend that you were in
the world where you only needed to work
with the finite case
so
what this looks like is that we can have
this net and that's here is defined as i
for every function in my original
function class there's this proxy in my
smaller net
where really in expectations these are
very close to each other an expectation
taken over the distribution that we
don't know but there exists such a net
and the net is small
and this net in the example i gave you
essentially look like the epsilon
intervals that i could have essentially
written these epsilon intervals only
picked these
hypotheses that are at the corners of
these epsilons and anything that falls
in the interval next to it is going to
be mapped to its proxy which is at that
discretization level
the discretization of course has to
depend on the distribution so
but
once you have such a just existence of
such a
such a
net you all you need to do is let's say
that this net is really good you know
not many uh instances can fall between
any of these grids because there was
very little probability there to start
that
and there are infinitely many these
little epsilon
kind of instances
intervals but they happen to be very
structured in particular they in this
case they have a very good vc dimension
and because of that we can take union
bond over infinitely many of them
so this is just an alternative
explanation of why we can learn in the
offline setting
um
and really it's about this empty
concentration of what happens in this
error
of uh
of the net
now the challenge here is that we cannot
really use this because when we have an
adversary the adversary can
exactly focus on any fixed net and try
to make the error very high in that area
and that's the issue
so
what we are going to see is that we can
preserve some of this
anti-concentratedness of
a
smooth sequence
because at any given time that adversary
who had to be sigma smooth cannot focus
too much on any of these intervals
and the hope should be that even by
correlating across the history he still
has very limited power of focusing on
any one interval
and that's what we are going to see
of course the challenge here is that
exactly these correlations because you
might worry that maybe at this time it
cannot focus too much but t is quite
large
and maybe
with sufficient patience it can start
focusing on some interval that i wasn't
thinking about
okay so how we're going to deal with
this challenge is that we're actually
going to try to connect anything that a
smooth adversary can do to anything that
a uniform adversary could have done
what does this look like
it says that i don't have to worry at
all about any of these adaptiveness of
an adversary
what i do need to do is to sort of
understand if the sequence
that can be created by an adversary
looks like a sequence that could have
been created by uniform distribution
and we do this via probability coupling
probability coupling at a high level is
just a joint distribution between these
two processes
and it's a joint distribution that has
some nice property so i can look at
anything in a support and i can sort of
compare something on the two sides of
the two distributions
and
our goal is going to be to couple a
sequence of smooth distributions
withdraws from a uniform distribution
what we can show is that we have such a
coupling so our coupling theorem which
is very general that goes beyond online
learning
is that
you can couple t draws from this
adaptive smooth adversary
with a little bit more than t t over
sigma essentially number of draws from
the uniform distribution
and what is the nice property about this
coupling it's a notion of um
it's a notion of uh
monotonicity that with high probability
the things that the adversary would have
produced were a subset of the things
that would have been produced by a
uniform adverse uniform distribution
okay
you mean like those are actually sets of
things these are yeah take a step
yeah
yeah curly braces are missing sorry
um and and not ordered the order doesn't
matter
okay so why is this a good property to
have essentially we know and agree that
uniform distribution is not concentrated
it's like the least concentrated
distribution you can think about
and if the things that the adversary is
is creating is going to be somewhat
a subset of this it's also not going to
be concentrated as long as i scale what
i mean by concentrated by this one over
sigma
in other words i kind of want to say
that that approximation error of the net
was small which is this um
the the symmetric difference between any
hypothesis and its proxy
and i know it's going to be small over
the uniform distribution and if it's
small over the uniform distribution and
uniform distribution is
going to be sort of overtaking whatever
the adversary is doing then also the
adversary cannot produce too many um
samples in that that region
and
because of that the adversary cannot
focus on any of those small epsilon
intervals that i was worried about
so that's that's that's the main um very
powerful but simple tool
that we have that essentially tells us
that adaptive adversaries cannot be much
worse than a stochastic adversary on a
slightly different time scale the t
itself is the time scale that's changing
okay so with that uh in mind how are we
going to really use this
tool as a pretty powerful weapon
we are going to think about this as just
repeating the stochastic analysis back
with slight changes
so we start by taking a finite
approximation over our hypothesis class
which finite approximation are we going
to take we don't have a distribution
anymore it's an adversarial world
what we're going to do is that we're
going to take one with respect to the
uniform distribution
y uniform
kind of makes sense you know our
sigma smooth distributions are worst
case scalings of these uniform
distributions so if you can do something
in expectation that looks good for the
uniform for one round without any
correlation it doesn't look that bad for
a sigma smooth distribution
once we have this net what are we going
to do with this net
well algorithmically and this this is an
algorithm not a computationally
efficient one but an algorithm
i'm just going to take this net and i'm
just going to pretend that this was my
class
and i'm going to then have a regret that
is scaling logarithmic with this
size of the h prime
it turns out that these nets we do know
that um they're they're not um
they're not that large
in particular
even you can think about this as just
taking a slightly tighter net on a
uniform distribution and they happen to
only have dependencies on um the log of
them happens to have dependencies that
is linear in bc dimension
so that's okay
so this is the first step we take the
net
once we have the net we know that an
expectation
no round can put too too high of a
probability of anything falling in the
error range the approximation error
then what we do is that we're going to
apply the coupling here
the coupling says that yeah we are
dealing with the adaptive adversary and
our net was for the uniform distribution
approximation error which is really
thinking about an expectation over all
of these correlated things and what
happens to the max
is going to still be bounded by this
monotonicity the nice property of the
coupling that we had
so this is going to allow us to really
take the fact that you know the
the things that the adversary generated
was a subset of the things that the
uniform distribution would have
generated to just say that we are back
in the uniform world
once we are back in the uniform world
then we can just bound the approximation
error based on the uniform distribution
this is where again the typical vc
theory magic comes in
there is nothing about adaptivity it's
just offline learning whatever you were
doing with offline learning and bc
dimension or coverage number they come
in here
so that's it
um this coupling method allowed us to
really go back from an adaptive
adversary to the uniform world to the
average analysis world
and we wanted to be robust to key
interactions with an adaptive smooth
adversary and what we saw was that
classical algorithms and analysis could
have been lifted
and used essentially directly in this
mooded adapted world
so i told you the story about online
learning but really this story is bigger
than online learning that was just one
clean example
this is true for any other adaptive
online process and and
decision problem we have
and our goals are the same which was
that we want to essentially get as best
performance as we can in the offline
world but in the online world
and what smooth analysis is saying is
that you can get rid of the worst part
of an adversary by using this coupling
by essentially reducing interactions
with an adaptive adversary to what would
have happened in the average case
analysis with a uniform distribution
a general recipe of how you would think
about applying this since we've applied
to a bunch of other problems is that you
just solve the problem for the uniform
case
and then go back and identify the steps
that anti-concentration was used
if worst case is much worse than average
case it's because anti-concentration was
used somewhere in the analysis
of the average case setting
once you identify them you'll notice
that they all actually have this type of
a
monotonicity properties either potential
function
um sometimes it's um
as you saw it was actually a coverage
function
all of these benefit from
anti-concentration
and all of them can be replaced with
this coupling lemma to just work with an
adaptive adversary rather than a uniform
one and then you just replace whatever
the coupling lemo tells you
and you're back
in the world
where the original problem held for the
uniform distribution
we have repeated just telling you
very quickly what we have done is that
this problem we've also applied to
online discrepancy minimization
if you're not familiar with this
you can think about this as having a
bunch of vectors that come one at a time
and they're in an l2 bound you have to
give plus and minuses to them like
cluster them in two settings
and you want these to look as
close as possible to each other so the
positive and the negative the negative
set then you just
take an average over them the vector is
as short as possible
and
we know that in the worst case
you cannot do better than square root of
t essentially because always the
adversary can give you something that's
not correlated
that's
orthogonal to the past
and
there are recent results in the average
case setting
either for uniform distribution or fixed
distributions or oblivious adversaries
that say that you can get this poly and
t type result
what we can show is that you can get
that poly anti poly log entry result
even for smooth adaptive adversaries
again using this type of a coupling so
again you can take the worst aspect of
an adversary out
and
get results that you could have gotten
for a fixed distribution
okay um that's that i just wanted to say
that i gave you one example in detail
one example pretty rush but this is a
bigger trend and this coupling lemma
itself was very simple but powerful in
trying to bring the typical
offline analysis to an adaptive smooth
analysis
some of the
we focus mostly on the information
theoretic aspects of learning
but the computational aspects are just
as important and there there's not
there's not a lot of work
um
in particular one open problem here is
that for the online learning world that
i gave you
um is there any computationally
efficient algorithm that
rather than the algorithm that's running
on the net
so that's one major open problem in this
space
more generally i just hope that you take
away from this talk that the
existing frameworks of beyond worst case
analysis that are
used for algorithmic analysis
have both very interesting and
challenging
open problems when it comes to learning
and also can bring a unique perspective
on learning because it's not just that
the computation is the thing that
they're trying to limit but they're
actually changing the characterization
of learnability even to start with
with that thank you i will take
questions
do you have any idea whether the uniform
distribution is sort of the best and
only distribution that you should use
you mean in terms of defining smooth
analysis at one over sigma no it's not
the only but we
we also don't think we can define it
based on any distribution there are some
regularity assumptions here okay do you
know of some case where like the uniform
distribution doesn't give you what you
want but maybe some other distribution
might we don't um
we don't because i think uniform is
somewhat
uh
to me is somewhat actually the
pessimistic like it's as if hey i don't
know anything about my distribution
except for the scaling if i assume
gaussian is as if i know a little bit
more but it's not something we've
thought about
[Music]
uh is there an analog
of this kind of result for uh multi-arm
simple multi-arm bandits
um so simple multi-arm bandits and you
mean like with bandits like actual
bandits right
um we haven't worked it out and
there essentially it's not just a
discretization that matters you also
care about how partial information comes
in
the main challenge there is that
it's not even we don't have actual
characterization of what the regret
should look like for any uh
continuous multi-arm banded problem
um it's not like we don't have easy
dimension we have some
some dimensions but they are usually
only bounding they regret upper bounding
it and not lower bounding it so absence
that characterization we are a little
bit in trouble making such a crisp story
but we do believe that it should help um
especially i can tell you that one of
the applications i didn't talk about
today is about online optimization um
beyond online learning and there
both the full information and the
partial information essentially use very
similar type of guarantees so i think in
limited scenarios we can definitely do
that but i think the story is not going
to be quite as clean here just because
the characterization is missing even for
the worst case
there is some understanding uh about how
like certain like like for example
linear contextual bandits like some
smoothing of those times
yeah so linear contextual bandits there
is some yeah so jamie
and collaborators and also
uh another paper from msr with um
i want to say manish or gabon and
collaborators
have some understanding for linear bands
but more generally as i said like
generally if you speak about any age
it's just we don't know even the
characterization for the worst case
i guess i have a very small question
that is
when i think about smooth analysis in
the in machine learning you know there
are kind of two worlds you could live in
one is like and it makes more sense for
this particular problem you're going to
smooth the distribution
but you could also consider smoothing
the function class
um
is there some um you know smoothed
function class that you've also
considered here or yeah so you could
smooth the function class and things
usually become much easier so so one
thing that is the real challenge here is
the correlatedness across
and the fact that you're still keeping
the little sun dimension as an at
infinity and you're creating these
correlated but smooth distributions
when you create a smoothed function
itself you're actually
changing its own uh right like
sequential marker complexity by adding
some luxuriousness to it
so
results first of all become much simpler
to to deal with but also a little bit
less robust to
um
to thinking about
thinking about the scale of noise the
meaning of the scale of the noise just
because these noises could sort of build
up and those noises don't build up just
because the function class itself the
licensed value of it was fixed
the noises
yeah so you have to prove that they
don't in some cases they could right in
these applications they don't
but uh yeah so so i guess long story
short
you could think about just looking at
sequential atomic or complexity of a
function class
and the function class itself being a
bit more smoothed i believe there was a
older paper
i'm worried that i might not actually be
citing the authors but i think it's shy
ben de veda and jai shalom schwartz and
perhaps one other author
um that looks at this kind of agnostic
learning when uh you're
making these thresholds to be a little
bit more lip [ __ ]
yeah so that is also very interesting
and something that people have thought
about a little bit
okay
[Applause]
uh